Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we have an animation movie or a computer
game with quadrupeds, and we are yearning
for really high-quality, lifelike animations,
motion capture is often the go-to tool for
the job.
Motion capture means that we put an actor,
in our case, a dog in the studio, we ask it
to perform sitting, trotting, pacing and jumping,
record its motion, and transfer it onto our
virtual character.
There are two key challenges with this approach.
One, we have to try to weave together all
these motions, because we cannot record all
the possible transitions between sitting and
pacing, jumping and trotting, and so on.
We need some filler animations to make these
transitions work.
This was addressed by this neural network-based
technique here.
The other one is trying to reduce these unnatural
foot sliding motions.
Both of these have been addressed by learning-based
algorithms in the previous works that you
see here.
Later, bipeds were also taught to maneuver
through complex geometry, and sit in not one
kind of chair, but any chair, regardless of
geometry.
This already sounds like science fiction.
So, are we done, or can these amazing techniques
be further improved?
Well, we are talking about research, so the
answer is, of course, yes!
Here, you see a technique that reacts to its
environment in a believable manner.
It can accidentally step on the ball, stagger
a little bit, and then flounder on this slippery
surface, and it doesn’t fall!
And it can do much, much more.
The goal is that we would be able to do all
this without explicitly programming all of
these behaviors by hand.
But, unfortunately, there is a problem.
If we write an agent that behaves according
to physics, it will be difficult to control
properly.
And this is where this new technique shines
- it gives us physically appealing motion,
and we can grab a controller and play with
the character like in a video game.
The first step we need to perform is called
imitation learning.
This means looking at real, reference movement
data and trying to reproduce it.
This is going to be motion that looks great,
is very natural, however, we are nowhere near
done, because we still don’t have any control
over this agent.
Can we improve this somehow?
Well, let’s try something and see if it
works!
This paper proposes that in step number two,
we try an architecture by the name generative
adversarial network.
Here, we have a neural network that generates
motion, and a discriminator that looks at
these motions and tries to tell what is real,
and what is fake.
However, to accomplish this, we need lots
of real and fake data, that we then use to
train the discriminator to be able to tell
which one is which.
So how do we do that?
Well, let’s try to label the movement that
came from the user controller inputs as fake,
and the reference movement data from before
as real.
Remember that this makes sense as we concluded
that the reference motion looked natural.
If we do this, over time, we will have a discriminator
neural network that is able to look at a piece
of animation data and tell whether it is real
or fake.
So, after doing all this work, how does this
perform?
Does this work?
Well, sort of… but it does not react well
if we try to control the simulation.
If we let it run undisturbed, it works beautifully,
and now, when we try to stop it with the controller…well,
this needs some more work, doesn’t it?
So, how do we adapt this architecture to the
animation problem we have here?
And here comes one of the key ideas of the
paper.
In step number three, we can rewire this whole
thing to originate from the controller, and
introduce a deep reinforcement learning-based
fine tuning stage.
This was the amazing technique that DeepMind
used to defeat Atari Breakout.
So what good does all this for us?
Well, hold on to your papers, because it enables
true user control, while synthesizing motion
that is very robust against tough, previously
unseen scenarios.
And if you have been watching this series
for a while, you know what is coming…of
course, throwing blocks at it and see how
well it can take the punishment.
As you see, the AI is taking it like a champ.
We can also add pathfinding to the agent,
and, of course, being computer graphics researchers,
throw some blocks into the mix for good measure.
It performs beautifully.
This is so realistic.
We can also add sensors to the agent to allow
them to navigate in this virtual world in
a realistic manner.
Just a note on how remarkable this is.
So this quadruped behaves according to physics,
lets us control it with a controller, which
is already somewhat of a contradiction.
And, it is robust against these perturbations
at the same time.
This is absolute witchcraft, and no doubt,
it has earned to be accepted to SIGGRAPH,
which is perhaps the most prestigious research
venue in computer graphics.
Congratulations.
What a
time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!